Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to "Infectionator 2"
and this is another flash game
and I know I've been playing a lot of flash games lately
but this is a good one
and I'm actually good at the game
which means I can show you how it's done without worrying too much
so the game is basically a zombie infection simulator
but not like pandemic or anything like that
what it is, is you start the zombie infection
and then they, of their own volition,
will go out into the entire world and then dominate
devastate, and kill everyone in the entire city that you're in
and then you go around, throughout the world
trying to make as many people go blurg  and die
because that's how people die in my mind the go blaurgh
and then you conquer the world with your zombies
so the first city is Bejing because for some reason a lot of zombie stories start in China?
and I don't even know why
If anyone has read the Zombie survival guide, handbook
it's a very interesting read but
I believe that as well has the zombie apocalypse starting from patient zero somewhere in China?
And, I don't know what they have against China... I personally don't have anything against China.
And also there's this lady who has way too much cleavage popping out of her shirt.
Anyway so you keep doing these over and over and there's specific objectives for these various levels
And eventually I'll get them good here, but I haven't bought any power ups yet because I don't have enough money to do so
And you continually level up over and over, through getting money and killing more and more people and your zombies become stronger and stronger
And then you get BONUS zombies, and then you get special-ultra-mega zombies, and then you get special items
And grenades that can blow things up and your ideal objective is to make sure that every city in the entire world is completely destroyed....
SO. Do you get it? D'you understand? It's
really cool. Now also if you go back to a city, you'll realize that there are objectives in the specific city.
Kill all in 40 seconds, gather 150 gold, kill one people with support, and then do it with no support.
So if you do that, the entire city will never ever ever rise from the ashes again and it will be gone forever
Which is either good or bad depending on your perspective on zombies and zombie apocalypses in general.
SO, that's my big spiel and now I'm done
Because apparently this didn't work, god damn it
See that didn't do anything because I only got one
Also, it's important to know that your - your zombie infection thing in the beginning has a spray pattern
Originally it goes in a cross-diagonal-plus sign, and then you'll eventually get more directions
If that sounds complicated and you have no idea what I'm talking about
You will in a second. So before I do that,
I'ma going to go to the next city so I can at least get bonus gold from this one
'cuz I suck
But I do know what I'm doing even though I suck
[stutter] Don't pay attention to that
Nothing about that makes sense.
Okay, so now I'm at the upgrade screen
and I actually have enough to be able to do these upgrades
Which make it slightly better
Slightly better. Not a lot better but slightly better
and slightly better is all we really need
Blecgh
There we go, there we go. This is getting better
That's more like it. Yeah. Yeah!
Yeeeah! Yeeaah!
Alright! So now we can get gre-NAH-des [grenades]
which are important because you want to be able to blow everything up
and once this is completely destroyed
kill one people with support is literally all I really need to do
Ha-bubrrrbp!
Look at that. Look at [muttering]
And then you can put all that down and kill everybody anyway
and then that's the end of that one. You get a thousand bonus gold.
and that's how you make a lot of progress in the game
It took me a while to realise that.
I didn't even understand what the mechanics of it was
at the first time that I did that.
But now, things are better.
Now I can move on to the next one and hopefully be able to do that
Bang. There we go. Got it.
Got it. Killed everybody. Killed one with grenade support.
That was a another one thing
And that was it! That was everything I needed to do for that one!
Yeah! Do you see what I mean?
Anyway, this game gets bigger and bigger
as you go through out the entire world and kill everybody in the entire world
[excitedly] And dominate everybody in every sector of anything that's going on here!
[quietly] but then you get a little ahead of yourself and you don't need to worry about that just yet
Ah, Singapore. I've never been
But eventually as you get through the game
you'll come across more resilient humans
Ones that are police officers and such
and you wanna make sure that you get them first
so that they don't shoot your zombies
and kill 'em before they have a chance to infect everybody
Which is actually kind of... kind of difficult to do
because in the beginning of the game, your chance of
them getting infected after you bite them
and murder them is actually kinda low
so you need to do it over and over again
so that you get enough money so that you're able to do what you need to do
And if I had more support, I probably could finish this level real quick.
Oh shit! How long was that do...? *gasp* FUUUUU-
[stammering] SORRY
I have no idea how long that was going on
One of the sides of the screen was cut off
It's not a problem that any of you worry about
but it's something that I have to worry about
as a "professional" Let's Player
Things go wrong! All the time!
And I have to make sure all the fires are put out.
Everything is dead!
Okay! So the other objective in this one
This is where things get kinda crazy
The maps get bigger and bigger and bigger
and that means more money, which is good, but
it gets bigger, bigger, and more complicated
to be able to kill everybody involved
so... and that sounds really morbid
but hey, you know, it's a game! It's a video game!
And I just got a new support thing called "land mines" or "trap"
They're literally land mines.
See, I don't know what malevolent force is
hovering above these cities causing all of this carnage.
Because zombies are one thing, but there's someone
that's throwing grenades and land mines from on high
and that sounds terrifying.
I have no idea why that happens,
but it just is what it is.
Oh come on get him get him get him! NOOOOO
YES! Hahahahaha!
And it's destroyed.
Singapore is gone! Sorry everybody
You thought I was bad starting off nuking Detroit
for a piece of cake
[laughing] I'm gonna to destroy the whole world!
Hahahaha!
Okay. Sorry.
I'm not sorry.
Just full - full declaration, there was another crisis
and you guys didn't see it, but everything is fine!
This recording is FINE!
This let's play is FINE!
You don't need to PANIC at all in the comments!
I know that happens a lot, but there's really no need this time
Anyway... just going to carry on like nothing happened.
Where are we now? I didn't even look where we were
but I'm going to assume it's a place with... rich culture
that I'm about to devastate
Yah know, a lot of historical history that happened
You know, historical history as opposed to anything else.
[shouting] I'M AN IDIOT WHO CAN'T SAY WORDS RIGHT!
If it wasn't obvious, I'm trying to speed run this
[stammering] I sped run my death.
Never mind! I'm not trying to do anything.
Now we're going to Jakarta
and again, I have no idea where that is.
Oh well! Let's try.
Well, that's not a good try because absolutely no one got anywhere.
[Laughing] It's re-... It's actually very difficult
to make sure that you-
The larger maps, you should save for later
because they might be attractive for money farming
down the road, but initially, they're not going to be ideal.
So you wanna make sure you get through the smaller maps first.
Oh come on! She's over there!
She said "gerberleigerber!"
Oh! [laughing] You did it!
Jakarta has been destroyed!
In one go!?
I'm devastating!
I am a menace to society!
(Exhale)
Yeah!
Alright, what else have we got?
Denpasar. If you're in any of these cities,
give a shoutout in the comments
because I have no idea if I'm infecting your hometown.
Okay. Well, that went pretty good
for the first try on that map.
Denpasar, sorry Denpasar
I just attacked you and didn't even... [trails off]
Let's see, what have we got here?
Tashkent! If anybody is watching this from Tashkent,
I'm sorry. The capital of Uzbekistan?
And the Tashkent...? Oh!
Well that sounds important!
I-I-I probably shouldn't do this, then!
Oh well. Already happening.
See, the good thing about this game is it's- it's quite addicting.
And- and the thing about addicting games is that
they need to be fun
And this one is actually one that's fun, even though
it doesn't feel like you're doing a whole lot.
I mean... again, that's a lot of things
that could describe my entire life, but for -
As far as things that don't feel like I'm doing a whole lot
it's fun in a way because it's a unique perspective
to this, like, game that kind of plays itself, if you know what I mean?
So it's-it's-it's
It gives that sort of aspect to it without too much brain power
but there is some strategy to it
because down the road things get really really hard
and as you dive deeper into like Russia and whatnot
it becomes obscenely hard to get everything done.
And there's the brute!
Who seems a lot like the tank from Left for Dead.
You guys are gonna see that.
Alright Urumqi! I'm coming back for you!
Get ready for some of this.
You weren't expecting this guy!
Big giant man.
Uh huh, almost. Aw, come on!
So clooooosseee!
The big guy only lasts so long, so he's not there forever.
It would be nice, though.
Alright, what have we got here?
Kabul! I know Kabul.
'Kay. Sorry Kabul.
Ha-blula!
Ah-ha!
Ha-bam!
There we go, that'll help.
I mean, it- it won't help THEM, but it'll help me
Aw man, so close. Only three guys left.
Damn it.
New Delhi! Oh! Hello everyone from New Delhi!
Sorry!
I can't help it! It's a game!
I have tooooooooo
Oh damn it, why'd that get no one?
What is this bull honky?
See, the- the harder and harder it gets based on more and more
uh soldiers and police officers
and people with guns that shoot you dead.
Which is good. And then you can get this character
called "Ill Kim Jong"
who is actually very potent because he raises zombies
from corpses,
which makes spreading the infection much, much easier
and I'll get him in a little bit as soon as I get through...
Perth?!?! Hey! That's where Ross is from!
Sorry Ross! Here goes Perth!
Although I- speaking of him... I don't know
if he'd be too upset about that.
Heh... ha-bep!
There we go. That's better.
I mean, not BETTER, still results in horrible zombie apocalypse
but better for me in terms of getting my gold
because that's all that matters in this game!
Whatever weird world conquering person I am
all I care about is money and zombies.
Awwwww.
I think that's Ross down there. He survived
to make more Mario Maker levels!
The douche.
Okay, go! Go! GO my zombos, go!
Don't just stand in a pile, KILL!
MURDER! MAIM! There we go.
I gotta actually destroy everything before it actually gets done.
Thanks boob news lady!
Alright! Adelaide! I think I've heard of Adelaide.
The cliffs of Adelaide? No, that's not what that is.
That's... that's definitely not a thing.
The cliffs of Adelaide are never a thing.
There we go. That ought to take care of it.
Ohp! Destroyed! I'm sorry, Adelaide.
It's a very pretty name! I'm probably not even
pronouncing the name of your city properly
I'm sure Ross will beat me up at the end of this episode.
Now I can get Ill Kill Ji- Ill Kim Jong!
And Ill Kim Jong will be released on ...
Sydney! Of all places.
Going to be a slightly bigger one. Ha-bah!
Ha-beh! Ha-beh!
And then Ill Kim Jong will be spawned right in the zombie pit there
so that all the corpses will be turned into zombos
Aw, almost there, just a little too spread out
Not enough infectivity.
That's the next thing I need on this.
I did unlock Russia, though.
So all my fans in Russia
you're about to be visited by zombies.
Actually, Russia is incredibly hard to penetrate.
Take that whatever way you want it.
Istanbul! I'm sure this is going to be difficult.
Tiny city, but it is still not going to be good
in terms of letting me destroy everything, I bet.
Ill Kim Jong! Get 'em!
The FBI is here!
Ooo, maybe maybe maybe. Maybe, maybe!
YEAH! I did it!
Okay what I'm going to do is I'm going to visit
all of these other cities, because I'm pretty sure it needs
you to visit the cities before it'll start unlocking things for you.
Plus, I need a lot more money. So I'm going to start
sweeping up the vbleh... I'm going to start
sweeping up the cities and then I'll get to
more destruction later.
Alright Russia, where are we starting? Oh god
Wha... What kinda name is that!?!
How am I- How am I, a stupid American man
supposed to pronounce Krasnoyarsk?
Is that even remotely close? Pro'ly not.
Too many soldiers here.
[most likely attempting to speak Russian and failing.]
is going down. Probably. Maybe.
Nope! All zombies killed. Wow.
They don't eff around. Okay, New Delhi!
I didn't even- I didn't even get close to doing anything
to New Delhi last time, apparently.
Aw, Ill Kim Jong, you're not supposed to be over there!
You're supposed to be where all the dead zombos are!
Alright. Fine. Whatever.
Oh, wow. I did okay! OHHH!
Oh, delightful!
Oh no, no! Get her, get her!
Gaaahhhhh! Come on! Aww! COME ON!
You were so close!
What a load of ass.
Alright, what about Brisbin? Brisbane. Bri- brisbin?
Brisban. Oh, there you are, piled off in a corner
not doing anything important with your life.
I mean, your un-un- undead life.
Your unlife. Oh get her! Get her!
Get her! Yayhahahey!
I'm so proud!
Of being a maniacal overlord
that tries to destroy Brisbin.
Brisbin.
Before I end the episode, I want to conquer all of Australia
That'll be like, my- my end goal here
Just be- Not- not that I- not that there's anything wrong with Australia
It's just
[Laughing] I know I have fans in Australia
What's the last one? Darwin.
Darwin is the last city, but I'll get to you in a second
I gotta get to [inhales] Sydney
Sydney, you're going down.
Everybody in Sydney, look out your window!
There's a zombie apocalypse happening. Oh come on!
Oh come on! Oh come on!
[sighs]
[quietly] Load of ass.
Yes. No! NO! Get the co... get the- AWWW
The police, where did they come from?
Where did they go?
Where did they come from, Cotton Eye Joe?
Okay, now, NOW we are the winners
Now, NOW we are do the good.
Yes, please, yes, yes, YES, YES, YES
I am very happy about Sydney being destroyed.
Ah, what do we have left? Let's see...
I just gotta kill all in 35 seconds here
I can do that! Yeas. Almost. Almost
Yes! Yes! Yes! YES!
I think that's all of Australia
Oh no wait, there was one more. There was one more.
One more holdout city in Darwin.
Well, Darwin you're not going to be lasting
much longer because you're too densely populated.
That's your problem here. [laughs]
And done! Holy crap! Everyone died!
[laughing] I didn't even pay attention
I was off in Lala Land
Now!  Now Darwin is going down
and I'm going to start with the grenades. Bohm. Kaboom!
Okay, there we go.
Heh-plublb!
Zombies! Sorry everybody.
Zombie attack. Right outside your windows.
Go go goooooo! YAY!
Alright, there we go.
ANNNDDD THERE we go. And
the en... the entirety of Australia has been destroyed.
My apologies to all my fans in Australia.
[outro music starts] But this game is very fun. Totally free
You can check it out through a link in the description below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and if you have fun games that you've played online
in the past that you want to see me play,
maybe some more ragey ones if you'd like,
let me know in the comments down below.
Thanks again everybody! And as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh bye!
[Markiplier Outro plays]